MATTEO VALLONE: My
name is Matteo Vallone,
and I work in apps and games
business development team.
And in my day to day job I
work with both apps and games
developers.
So I thought it would
be interesting for you
as app developers
to learn more about
what successful games
developers care about.
And not only that, I will
try to extrapolate some rules
that you can apply in
your day to day job.
And, also, I will
show some examples
of how these rules have been
applied by apps developers.
But before that I want to spend
some time talking about why
we think games and
apps should learn
from each other-- what are
the relevant things that they
have in common.
But I don't want to
oversimplify this.
Actually, I want to address
the elephant in the room
right away.
It's much more difficult to
make money on apps than games.
We all know that.
And it's not only because
it's generally more accepted
to pay for games than apps,
but also because games
have much more flexibility
in their mechanics
and what they can do to
actually monetize users.
They're also selling
virtual goods.
So there's endless
possibilities what they can sell
and the price points
they can put together.
So they basically
can do whatever
they want in terms of
selling virtual currencies
or virtual goods in a game.
For apps that's not possible.
But the math is always the same.
Apps and games, in
both cases, the model--
the dominant model--
is the freemium model.
That means that this
equation on the right
here, that is always true.
CPI, cost per install,
for your installs
should always be lower than
the lifetime value of the users
that you're bringing in.
And that means that
in a world where
CPI is rising
because there's more
competition for servicability,
for user acquisition,
in order to make
this function work
you really need to focus on the
right side of this equation.
And lifetime value is a function
of retention, engagement,
and conversion,
and monetization.
But it all starts with
retention because that's
what drives engagement.
That's a measure of
engagement, and that's
what drives monetization.
So retention is king.
This data from a mobile
intelligence company, Quettra,
show how, actually, this is
so important for both apps
and games.
Here you see a comparison
of retention curves of apps
based on Google
Play Store ranking.
Here you see that the top
games and the top apps,
they all have better
retention than the ones below.
So even if the curves are
a little bit different,
games tend to have
shorter term retention
because they are less-- they
have less longevity than apps.
In general this is always true.
So it's not only something
that games developers
should care about--
also apps should really
care about retention.
And going a bit further in
retention, the key metric
that you should
look at when you try
to optimize your
long-term retention
is frequency, because
that shows how many times
a user comes back to your app.
If users come back
to your app often,
chances are they will
get hooked by it.
They will make it part
of their daily routine.
That means they will be retained
and they will become your users
forever, hopefully.
This graphic shows
how different apps
category and games
genre have-- they
are mapped along two metrics.
One is the frequency per
week-- so how many times
a user visits on average
those apps in a week.
And the day 90 retention--
so the long-term retention,
the end of that curve
that I showed before.
You see that, while they are
different-- it depends on where
you are in this category--
there is a direct correlation
between the two.
All right.
So retention is king.
And games know this very well.
They spend a lot of time
optimizing for that,
and you see how--
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
-The icon needs to appeal.
[END PLAYBACK]
MATTEO VALLONE: Sorry.
You see how pretty much every
successful game developer--
and there are a few
highlighted here--
they tend to before launching
a new game to the public,
they do what we
call soft launching.
They pick a test market
or a beta community,
and they spend a lot of
time optimizing their game,
tweaking it to the point where
the retention figures are
satisfactory.
And this process requires
a lot of discipline.
A lot of games get killed
during this process.
But it also ensures that
they invest resources
in the right product that
actually has a chance
to be successful and
where that equation
that I showed you before works.
If you don't do this
already, retention
can be measured very easily
through Google Play-- so sorry,
through Google Analytics.
And this is the
report that you can
look at that shows on the
top, your retention curve.
This is your app
retention curve.
And also, it shows a
breakdown of retention figures
by cores of users that install
the app in a given day.
So you can also optimize and
see how it impacts retention.
All right.
So now let's talk
about some things
that you can actually
learn from the games world
and apply in your
day to day job.
The first one is focusing
on engagement cliff.
This is very important.
And I'm showing you again the
chart with retention figures
because there's something
else that can be noted here.
You see how in each
case regardless
of how successful the
app is, most of the users
are lost in the
first seven days.
That's where everyone loses.
And actually, the
top apps are the ones
that are doing a
better job, especially
in the first seven days.
After that the curves tend
to flatten for everyone,
so there's not much difference
between different apps.
But those first seven
days are critical.
Here you see on the right an
average day seven retention.
So after those seven
days, how many users
are still in the app
for different categories
on average.
Again, this is Quettra data.
And you see how it varies
between 40% and 15%.
That means that, on
average, 60% to 85% of users
are lost in those
first seven days.
And that's because users
need to try an app.
They install a lot of
apps, but then they try it.
And in those first few
days they actually decide
whether they want to still use
it, or just leave it there.
Once they decide, once
the app is good enough,
then chances are the
users will stick.
And actually, that's why
the curves flattens here.
But those first seven
days are critical.
Games know this very well.
In a game onboarding
is quite challenging.
You have to teach a user new
rules, new mechanics, why
you should care, what is
the story, lots of things.
So it all starts
with a tutorial.
And I want to show you
an excerpt of a video
that we recently shot with
a very successful game
developer called Pixelberry
that has a great completion
rate for its tutorial.
70% of people that
actually start a tutorial
go through each section
of the tutorial.
So let's play the video
and we'll comment that.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Players coming in, we hit
them with story right away.
And we try and do
it in a way where
it's a little more natural.
We are cognizant that a
lot of people playing games
on mobile phones may not
want to read too much text,
so we try to ease
players into that.
But by the time they
finish our tutorial,
we're hoping that
they're already caught up
in the lives of these
characters and they
want to learn more
about their back stories
and what's going on.
-I think it is
important to give people
kind of that sense
of progression
in a game-- especially
in mobile games.
Because I think that
in a lot of games
that you can reach a certain
point where you're just
repeating the same actions, and
you want to feel like you're
doing something different.
And I think story is a
great way of differentiating
that and saying, oh, now you're
dealing with a new villain,
or now you're dealing with
a new issue that's come up.
[END PLAYBACK]
MATTEO VALLONE: So they
talk about two key things.
One is the story-- they
use story to hook players
right away, and
they rely on that
to make sure that it's
compelling for the user
to stick around for
the whole tutorial.
The other thing they talk
about is progression.
Progression is very
important in games
because, if you think about it,
the game is always presenting
you with a new challenge.
If you get a sense
of progression,
you keep playing the game--
otherwise it gets boring.
Those challenges shouldn't
be too challenging,
otherwise you leave the game.
So it's always finding
the right balance
between making you stick around
to play the next challenge,
but it's not too
difficult for you.
And I actually want to show
you this concept of progression
and onboarding goes beyond a
tutorial with the other example
of Playdots, another very
successful game developer.
This is a chart that
shows all their levels.
They are mapped
along two metrics--
one is revenue per
player in that level,
and lapse rate-- how many people
left the game in that level.
By tweaking the difficulty
level and the experience
in the levels that are
below the red lines,
for the under-performing
ones, they actually
managed to improve
not only retention
but also average
revenue per paying user.
So again, the message
here is-- this
is very specific to
games, of course--
but the message is it's not
only about the tutorial,
it's about how you
communicate and foster a sense
of progression within the game.
OK.
Let's try to extrapolate
some rules for apps now.
The important thing here is
that in the first seven days
there is an engagement cliff.
The user is presented
with a new app.
They have to understand how it
works and start playing with it
and understand the value.
And you want to ease that
cliff as much as possible
to help them going
through those seven days
to the point where they
will probably stick around.
So the first thing
to do is finding
features that provide
value to the user
without asking much from
them-- something that you
can show them and they
can experience right away.
And after that you need to
understand the activation
moments.
What are the key things that
you want the user to do in order
to fully experience your app and
that requires some engagement
some commitment?
For example, creating an
account, uploading a video,
finding some friends, adding
some preferences-- something
that personalizes and
makes the experience deeper
but requires also some
actions from the user.
And you should present
those things gradually.
You should help them going
through each one of them
step by step instead
of overwhelming them
with everything
at the same time.
As a consequence,
also, part of that
is that you should manage
the appearance of pay walls,
especially in those
first few days.
You don't want to scare
people off or overwhelm them
with the requirements.
So that's the general rule.
And something that can
help you optimizing
your app along this
rule is the flow report
in Google Analytics.
This shows you how
users, on average,
move between different
screens in your app.
You can see the path they take.
And more importantly,
with the red lines here
you can see where they
get out of the app.
What are the friction points?
What are the roadblocks?
And potentially remove some
of them, if it makes sense.
So very useful report to use.
And I want to show you
an example of an app that
did a great job applying
these rules recently
when they redesigned
their own boarding flow.
Overall they achieved
20% better day
seven retention, which
is a great figure.
The way they did it is that--
first of all, let's talk
about dating sites and apps.
They require a lot of things to
set up before you can actually
enjoy and use that dating app.
You have to create an account.
You have to write
something about yourself.
You have to start answering
some questions about yourself,
liking some people,
and uploading
a photo-- a lot of things to
do before you can actually
use the app.
They redesigned their onboarding
to make it more gradual
and step by step.
And I'll show you
what I mean exactly.
First of all, this is
what they had before.
They required you to write
an essay about yourself,
upload a photo,
answer some questions,
and like some people all
together in the same section
of the app and with a
series of modal windows
with no clear sequencing.
So the user felt a bit
overwhelmed and like, oh, wow,
there's a lot of things that
I have to do before I can even
use this app.
And if you see on
the right, that's
just answering the questions.
Even when you go in
one of the tasks,
it feels quite
overwhelming because you
have to do-- it's
not that engaging
and there's a lot of things
you have to go through.
So this is how it looks
after the redesign.
The first thing you see
when you download the app
is five questions
about yourself.
It's very easy to
go through them.
Right, yes.
You swipe right, it's yes.
Swipe left, it's no.
Once you finish
that, then you're
only then asked
to upload a photo.
If you want, you can skip this.
So you can enjoy the
app even if you don't
want to upload a photo now.
But that's the only thing
you need to care about.
After that, then you can
start enjoying the app.
And you are also
reminded of other things
that you should be doing in
order to fully experience
the app, but it's
just a call to action,
and you can do it
whenever you want.
And again, this is step by step.
Once you do this, then they push
you another other action to do.
So it goes from a very
low engagement, very easy
to go to tasks, to a bit more
complex once you actually
start enjoying the app.
All right.
So now, users have
decided to stick around.
You've done a great job of
onboarding and communicating
that sense of progression.
Well, let's talk about
how you can monetize them.
I want to talk about
how games look at this.
Even the most successful
games, no matter
what you do a big
percentage of users
will never spend a
dime in that game,
and games developers
are cognizant of that.
The key thing there is
identifying as soon as possible
the users that are
more likely to spend
and start targeting them.
And even then, once you identify
the people that are actually
going to spend, understanding
how much they are
willing to spend
is really powerful
because different users will
have different propensity
to buy-- and targeting them
with a different experience
or different offers
is where you can
optimize much more than applying
a one size fits all approach.
I want to show you who
does a great job of this.
This is Space Ape, a
successful game developer.
Their games are Samurai
Siege and Rival Kingdom.
What they do here is
they segment users
based on the first
seven day behavior.
And they calculate, they
predict the lifetime
value of each user based on the
way they engage with the game.
And also they tag them with
different spend patterns
the way they spend and buy
things within the game.
And then they start
targeting these users
with different offers.
Let me show how it works.
Here are all the users.
They're hitting
Space Ape servers.
Space Ape starts analyzing
them, and then they're
assigned to a segment.
Here they have five segments.
I want to show you
just two as an example.
One is predicted to have
a medium lifetime value,
but the pattern
here is that they
spend a lot in one single
chance, in one single purchase,
and then they tend not to
spend too much too often.
The other group is higher
actually lifetime value.
But in a single spend
they spend less,
even if they are predicting
that over time these users are
spending more-- in
a single spend point
they tend to spend less but
the frequency will be higher.
So then they expose them
to different offers,
different bundles of items--
where the medium lifetime
value with a high single
spend point and low
spend frequency sees a very
big bundle with lots of stuff
in it, quite expensive.
But it's just buy it once and
probably you never come back.
You're going to use it
for the rest of the game.
While the medium spend
point sees a smaller
a bundle, cheaper,
but probably you're
going to come back and buy more.
So that's very powerful.
And if you want to
extrapolate a rule for it
from for the apps
world is you first,
though, have to realize that
different users are going
to want something
different from your app--
and especially they will
have a different value
perception and a different
propensity to spend.
And if you can identify
them and target them
with a different offer that is
more customized around that,
that's where you can optimize
your conversion much more
effectively.
A tool that you can use to
start learning about your users
and how the different
segments behave and start
thinking about what
you can actually
do to tailor their experience
is again Google Analytics.
This is the segment
builder in Analytics.
It lets you create segments
with lots of options.
I want to show you
just the behavior
category of those options.
You have sessions, days
since last session,
transactions, and
session duration--
so you can create a segment
based on that for example.
And here we have two groups--
one is highly engaged people,
and the other one is
less engaged users.
And those segments
will then be exposed
in pretty much every report
that is in Google Analytics.
So, for example, this
is the revenue report,
and you see, instead of
one line for revenues
you see revenues for highly
engaged users and revenues
for less engaged users.
So you can really start
understanding how they behave
and what is bringing
you each segment.
Who does a great job in the apps
world targeting different users
with different value
proposition is Wish.
It's an e-commerce app.
And very simply,
they have a group
of people that are less engaged
and one is more engaged.
To the less engaged
people, the feed
of products that
they recommend is
less expensive because it
requires less commitment
and less engagement to actually
think of purchasing them.
Well, once they see more
engagement and some conversion,
they start recommending
more expensive products.
So quite simple, but it lead
to 10% better conversion just
by doing that.
All right.
The last one I want to
show is selling umbrellas
where and when it rains.
This is how you sell products
instead of what you sell.
If you look at this
screenshot from Pretty Simple,
another game developer--
Pretty Simple Games--
they made an art, not only
a science, out of this.
And I want to show
you an example of how
this can be really optimized.
Playdots-- again,
they are the developer
we talked about before
with the progression chart,
they also redesigned
their purchase flow
across the whole game.
And overall they achieve
10% better revenue
per active user, which is
a big number because it's
for all users, including the
ones that are not paying.
So overall, 10% revenue per
user is quite an achievement.
And I'll show you a couple
of examples of what they did.
The first one is, before
you start a level,
you see a card that shows you
some stats of what you have,
and it prompts you to
buy things that you
might need in that level.
It's not the whole
store, it just
prompts you to buy specific
things-- in this case
it's boxes-- that you might
need in that specific level.
And similarly, when
you die in a level--
basically you run out of
moves-- the first thing
you see is a button that
lets you buy extra moves that
lets you finish that level.
Instead of starting
over again and just
going back to the
store and buying those,
you can buy them now and
keep playing the level.
By doing this, they obtained
6% more paying users
just by adding these
two call to actions.
The other thing they did,
they moved some products--
some in-app products--
within the game experience.
So instead of having them
exposed in the store only,
they also highlight them
on the bottom of the game.
So whenever you want
while you're playing,
you can purchase them.
And it's one tap.
This led to 5% better ARPU.
Overall, if we want to simplify
and generalize this for apps,
it's about selling umbrellas
where and when it rains.
It's not only making purchasing
accessible and easy for users
so that it's as close as
possible to their experiences--
one tap away or two taps away.
But also triggering
some call to actions
when and where it's very
relevant, that specific product
that you're selling.
Who does a great job at this
in the apps world is TomTom.
They recently moved from
premium to freemium,
and they sold 2.4 times
more paying users.
And that's because they
moved in the right way.
They actually thought
about their business model
and how they could
sell upgrade to premium
in a very clever way.
I want to show you how.
The model is that you have
75 kilometers for free.
You can use the app
for 75 kilometers
and you don't have to pay.
It's a real metering model.
It's real meters.
And then you can upgrade
to one year or three year
subscriptions.
And the first thing
they did is that they
made that upgrade bottom
always available there.
It's on the bottom of the app.
Wherever you are in
the app you see that.
It's one tap away--
you can upgrade.
And you also see the countdown--
how many kilometres for free
you still have.
So 75, 74, 73-- you
see the progression
and you know when you
need to hit that button.
The other thing they did-- very
similarly to the other example
I showed you-- they
trigger some call to action
when it's quite relevant.
For example, if you
start a new trip,
they know that
you're probably going
to run out of kilometres
because that trip is quite long
and you only have 40
kilometers, for example.
They trigger a call
to action that says
do you want to upgrade now.
It's better,
probably, because you
don't want to upgrade
when you're driving
or you might not have a
connection or you're abroad.
So things like that they also
trigger a call to action when
you're actually running
out of kilometers
and when you run
out of kilometres.
But the point here is that it's
relevant and it's easy to do it
and I understand why
I should purchase
the upgrade in this moment.
All right.
To wrap up, the
rules are three-- one
is addressing the onboarding
as an engagement cliff.
And so, start by analyzing your
day one to day seven retention
figures in Analytics.
And thinking about
activation moments that
are gradually more
invested for the user,
and how you can introduce
them in the app.
The second one is embracing
your apps multiple personality
disorder-- so understanding
that different users want
different things and
you can target them
with different ways, especially
when it comes to in-app offers
and propensity to buy.
And the third one is about
not only what you sell,
but how you sell it.
And we say that it's
like selling umbrellas
where and when it rains.
Make it easy for people to
buy, but also very relevant,
and triggering
call to action when
you think the most chances are
that the user will convert.
So, thank you for
listening today.